good morning everyone my name is dr.
Miller and the SCP were going to be
looking at today is SCP 4018 object
class safe special containment
procedures as CP 4018 is to be kept in
sight 57s low-risk anomalous object
storage vault no imagery of SCP 4018 may
be distributed to any media outlet any
photographs or videos of SCP 4018 found
outside of containment must be destroyed
any activation of SCP 4018 s anomalous
effect constitutes a breach of secrecy
when this occurs as CP 40 18 is to be
acquired or reacquired by the foundation
as soon as possible to this end both
conventional retrieval methods and
sabotage of SCP 4018 a are permitted as
CP 40 18 s power over the foundation if
any must be negated containment
operations are considered finished once
SCP 4018 a is no longer active once this
occurs and the evidence of SCP 4018 must
be erased from the public record when
possible falsified records should be
provided to replace the removed
information description SCP 4018 is
anatomical model of a human eye
constructed of ivory and horn it's
design is consistent with similar models
constructed in Europe in the 17th
century
as CP 40 18 is significantly more
resistant to damage than its composition
would indicate as CP 48 teens anomalous
effects activate when a photograph or
video of it is published by a media
outlet hereby SCP 40:18 a when this
occurs as CP 48 teenage control over SCP
48 teen will become directly correlated
with its success for as long as it is
extant physical possession of SCP 40:18
legal ownership of it or power over any
party that possesses or owns SCP 40 teen
corresponds to higher earnings greater
financial stability wider viewership or
readership and a more public and
critical regard the reverse is also true
additionally while SCP 4018 s anomalous
effects are active the concept of SCP 48
teen a success will become
indistinguishable from that of its
control over a CP 48 teen subjects will
use the two concepts interchangeably in
all situations without any discernible
loss of meaning knowledge of one concept
confers a similar degree of knowledge
about the other for example a subject
that knows SCP 48 teens exact location
and legal status will also have detailed
knowledge about SCP 4018 A's viability
and vice versa
this effect makes it difficult to
ascertain the exact nature of the
correlation between SCP 4018 age control
over SCP 4018 and its success as
subjects who consider the two concepts
identical will fail to make the
distinction necessary to properly trace
cause-and-effect relevant records made
while SCP 4018 is active have not been
interpreted usefully after the fact and
are often barely legible it is being
hypothesized that a cp-40 18 s effects
are ontological ie that SCP 4018 a
success and its control over SCP 4018
become truly identical for the duration
of the effect rather than merely
impossible for humans to discern if true
this would account for the practical
correlation between the two as well as
the cognitive effects however it is not
currently possible to test this
hypothesis SCP 4018 can affect multiple
instances of scp-1407
when this occurs fierce competition
between SCP 4018 a instances often
ensues the exact nature of which is
difficult to concern
recovery note that the following
material attempts to describe specific
events that occurred while SCP 4018 was
active and must may be confusing for
readers attempts to obtain a clearer
understanding of these events are
ongoing SCP 40:18 was discovered
following the arson of a US Army
recruiting office in Columbus Ohio a
local news station received an anonymous
letter containing a cp-40 a teen and a
video cassette tape depicting an
unidentified individual designated Pio
i-40 18-0 committing the arson in
question the video transcribed below
prominently features SCP 4018 in a shot
also containing Pio I 40 18 zeros things
editor's note this section may require a
rewrite to comply with quality standards
reason other unspecified with the
approval of the local police department
broadcast the image of Pio i-40 18 zeros
face in an attempt to identify the
individual thus subjecting to its effect
this resulted in a negotiation of public
outcry away from scp-1432 ward the
foundation albeit at the cost of armed
coverage ultimately the foundation
destroyed with a targeted thankfull
campaign thus securing a cp-40 18 with
minimal casualties addendum transcript
of video log 40 18 0 the footage appears
to have been shot with a cell phone
camera presumably it was transferred to
videotape afterwards the footage begins
abruptly with the camera operator Pio
i-40 1804 in gasoline from a gas can
onto various surfaces of the recruiting
centers interior after two minutes the
subject exits through the front door
taking several seconds to prop it open
with a nearby doorstop
okay yeah [ __ ] man I recorded the whole
big thing about why I'm doing this and
what my kind of worldview is but then I
realize that no one cares and the only
important part of this video it's going
to be in the end so you get the short
version Pui 40 18 zero continues to pour
gasoline as they back roughly 15 meters
away from the building
then tosses the empty jug to the side to
say real quick head I'm sorry sorry that
I can't do anything except mess with the
media wall the planets burning obviously
but also I'm sorry for forcing these the
sound of a lighter being activated off
screen bo I 40 18 0 tosses a lip liner
onto the ground igniting the gasoline
the fire spreads towards the recruitment
center shortly after it reaches the
interior the building goes up in flames
P oh I forty eighteen zero sets the
camera on an unidentified surface and
steps in front of it for the first time
due to the abnormal lighting conditions
and low quality of the video the
subjects demographic information cannot
be discerned as CP 40 18 is located in
the subjects left eye socket
pío i-40 18 0 r Aizaz their hand to
their face and attempts to pull a cp-40
18 out of their eye socket the recording
ends abruptly after several seconds
okay I think that about does it for
today thank you for listening if indeed
you still are
and you were all dismissed goodbye I
[Music]
would like to give a special thank you
to albino Neku geum's Sabah Andre
Bichette Jax Merrick Pablo ice 917
Burlington the cat all the time gaming
Justin day researcher bull veer Pierce M
Hamlin Curie kuma white crew Nicholas
James Vujic Bryce and Billy my archive
curator Nick
Cody tench the Android slump god quartz
5 6 3
I'm tree hero thank you all so much for
your support
it's greatly appreciated if you would
like a special thank you at the end of
each of my videos on some other cool
stuff as well visit patreon.com forward
slash the Volga thank you
[Music]
[Music]
you